wir haben heute besuch von richard
richard woher kommst du ich komme aus
england und was machst du in berlin
ich werde bald meinen master anfangen
und ich bin gerade übersetzer und wie
hast du uns eigentlich kennengelernt
ritscher ich habe ja noch hier auf der
straße kennen gelernt genau hier an
dieser stelle in der kastanienallee und
wir haben uns super verstanden und ich
habe ihm gesagt dass ich ihm gerne bei
einem video helfen würde und schon bist
du nach was ist heute unser thema unser
thema heute ist das highlight der woche
was war dein highlight der woche das
wirtschaft jetzt auf der straße wissen
hier ist ein mikrofon
danke
[Musik]
was war für dich das highlight der woche
wir sind seit einer woche in berlin und
eigentlich war jeden tag so ein bisschen
highlight aber ich glaube wahrscheinlich
dass rumlaufen durch die verschiedenen
vierteln und einfach irgendwas ob sie es
nun in der sonne zu sitzen irgendwie
sowas war für euch das highlight der
woche oder für dich für mich das
highlight dass diese beiden leute die
man vielleicht wählen müsste sonst ist
es komisch mich besucht haben in berlin
du wohnst in berlin für einen monat
einfach okay kommt ursprünglich aus der
schweiz interessiert ich ja ne ist das
dein erstes mal in berlin haben wir aber
das erste mal so länger ok wo kommt er
her
wir wurden gerade in lüneburg aber ich
komme gebürtig aus braunschweig
okay das wetter gestern ok und was habt
ihr gestern gemacht die an der sonne
getrunken
typisch manchmal mein highlight der
woche war
nachmittags mit meinen freunden tisch
schnell verspielen ok wo hast du das
gemacht napa valley also hier ganz in
der nähe da hinten und war so nicht
schön heute hatten wir ein festival in
pankow und da waren wir heute mit den
kindern was habt ihr dort gemacht wir
haben gelesen als auch gegeben
die kinder sind mit der eisenbahn
gefahren kinder geschminkt okay so was
also familienfest ja familienfest und wo
kommt er her aus kolumbien ökonomien ja
meine cousine hat geheiratet und im
sauerland
genau ich war eine dort das war ich
durfte meine freundin leider nicht
mitbringen so blöd es klingt aber weil
die hochzeit so schon groß war irgendwie
ist zu klein zu halten wir haben jetzt
ziemlich große familie
mein highlight der woche war der salsa
tanzkurs havana club in schöneberg
ok also zum beispiel war das dein erstes
mal dort
das ist profi tänzer nicht profi tänzer
aber amateur tanz also macht sie das
spiel spaß und was hast du gemacht
während du alleine
nicht wahr in der schweiz und war segeln
auf dem thunersee ok und wo kommst du
her
ich komme ursprünglich aus dinslaken das
projekt um die ecke wohnt seit fünf
jahren in berlin zur frage der woche
dass meine mutter gestern zu besuch war
und was habt ihr gemacht und wohnungen
angeschaut das war nicht so ein
highlight für dich ziehst du nicht
irgendwie ja
du ziehst aus prenzlauer berg weil es
die nicht mehr gefällt nein ich ziehe
wieder in den prenzlauer berg ich habe
einen jahr nicht in berlin gelebt nach
so sondern ich bin gereift
mein highlight der woche gott die woche
fängt doch erst am morgen hatte mein
highlight der woche diese woche das muss
ich überlegen
ich war am see mittwoch am see letzten
sonnenstrahlen genossen an welchem sie
in südbrandenburg am grünewald und du
hast gewartet ich habe gewalt und
gegrillt barbecue woche war dass zwei
freunden aus zwei aus spanien nach
berlin gekommen sind
also du wohnst in spanien und deine
freundinnen im schwimmbad oder am see
gespannt sind meine kinder halten mich
auf trab ich habe vier von den vier
jungs okay
und was ist so spannend oder schwierig
an den kindern die sind unberechenbar
ich habe mein erster job wieder in
berlin angetreten das war mein highlight
als als anwalt als anwalt
ja genau haben sie ein beispiel
ich glaube der größte größte
schwierigkeit oder größte konflikt an
jedem eines täglichen lebens mit meinen
kindern ist er mir dass sie die grenzen
und regeln einhalten und dass sie
verstehen wir dass diese gesellschaft
wenn wir auf grenzen und regeln
aufgebaut ist dass wir in einem
rechtsstaat leben und dass ich nicht
machen können was sie wollen
ok und sie brauchen noch ein bisschen
zeit um das richtig zu begreifen
sie brauchen zeit um das richtig bewegen
und das dauert sehr sehr lange glaube
ich wie alt sind ihre kinder sie sind
sieben acht zehn und einer wird jetzt
demnächst 18
ok klingt nach viel arbeit genau aber
der 18 jährige engländer hat es
begriffen
der zehnjährige sollte das langsamer ich
verstehen der mir und ich habe die
befürchtung dass es noch ein sehr sehr
langer weg werden wird dann wünsche ich
ihnen viel glück dankeschön richard was
war eigentlich ein highlight der woche
ich war in österreich letzte woche und
bin an einem tag fahrrad gefahren nach
münchen
150 kilometer 150 in einem tag ja es hat
zwölf stunden gedauert 12 stunden 12
stunden vielleicht sogar mehr
das ist ziemlich grad und außerdem habe
ich bei easyjet mitgemacht
das wäre mein zweites highlight das ist
auch ein sehr gutes highlight wird zu
wissen was mein highlight ist ja wir
haben gerade eine e-mail bekommen aus
mexiko von einer sprachschule und die
haben einen super schönes video für uns
gemacht und uns eingeladen ihre stadt zu
besuchen und davon will ich so
überrascht so also das fand ich so cool
das war ein highlight der woche cool und
jetzt wollten natürlich wissen was für
euer highlight der woche schreibt es uns
auf deutsch in die kommentare dass es
auch für euch eine gute möglichkeit
deutsch zu üben und wenn dann noch
weiter geben wollt könnt ihr auch
interaktive übungen machen als patchen
zahlt ihr einen dollar pro woche bekommt
jede woche ganz besondere übungen und
vokabeln von uns und hier könnt ihr sie
german abonnieren
und dann freuen wir uns wenn ihr das
macht die altstadt wir gehen jetzt noch
was essen da zum werden lesen
er hat ja nicht dass schon gesagt na gut
dann gehen wir los
wenn wir noch werbung für den gewesen